no this is not a crime scene from Dexter
Kids Choice Awards on Nickelodeon
tomorrow coasted by Nate we are ready
for a little slime time in the studio so
we asked you our favorite viewers to
vote on social media to decide who
should get slime this morning the
options are the very handsome Tony
decopo Vlad dutier new dad new dad
this is our senior producer Matt Shelley
and this is a lovely jerika Duncan so
jarika I'm told that your daughter
Journey was hoping you would do this is
that why you're participating
I'm not used to having a mic like this I
know me that's exactly what she's hoping
for okay and Matt Shelley have you been
rallying all of your friends every
single person I know ever and they
rallied every single person they knew
but but what is that but they voted for
you to be slime
and you call them friends yeah yeah okay
I want to win well you uh up until like
yesterday morning winning the poll is
finding it differently I will say I have
I have confirmed that my wife voted for
me to be slime I voted for black what
okay I thought you were my friend
Tony
is here the winner is Tony vladrica Matt
Shelley it's you
[Applause]
I'm asking you do you want me to just
throw it in your face or pour it on the
top of yourself
no the ingredients the ingredients are
still a secret but I'm told that it's
very cold and Matt Shelley can I just
say I adore you I think you're very good
at what you do no no no no
you're going down
oh
what just they said get rid of them just
dunk the guy here we go
I don't want your it to get in your nose
[Laughter]
this is what they said to me
oh
brutal what does that feel like Matt
Lick It
what does that feel like Matt Shelley
is it too soon to toss the commercial
kid can we toss the commercial no no no
no no we want we don't want anybody to
miss out on this experience so I brought
some backup with me I'm going to step
out of the shot back up what do you mean
Backup backup let's go back up let's go
[Music]
you're not supposed to eat it
[Applause]
no
oh my God are you okay
let the people see you
I know all right
can I just say ladies can I just say
ladies and gentlemen we are all adults
here I know it looks like there were all
12 or 13 years old and I'm so happy that
I didn't get slimed at all we thank you
thank you no no no no no because I gotta
catch a plane yeah we thank you guys we
thank you
christening journey journey is very
proud of you jerika Nickelodeon likes oh
yeah good idea Nickelodeon like CBS is
part of Paramount Global the Kids Choice
Awards
well era live on Nickelodeon tomorrow at
seven o'clock
Eastern
coming up next all that matters are we
insured for this how old are these guys
coming up next all that matters this
week and we'll be right back
oh